and now nine urban dictionary
definitions every college student should
know Rhonda booze a designated time in
place to drink with friends Molly set
the rendevouz for 9 p.m. at dirtbags
struggle bus a particularly heavy course
load Ted can't make the rendevouz
because he is on the struggle bus sniff
test an olfactory exam of previously
worn clothing Jeff will wear the same
shirt from last night because it passes
the sniff test chipmunking to cram for a
final by listening to recorded lectures
at double speed Ted is on the struggle
bus because he is chipmunking for poly
SCI dweet to tweet while drunk
Jenny dwee today terrible selfie from
the bar bathroom shambles a state of
embarrassment and confusion the
rendevouz went to shambles when jenny
picked a fight with the bouncer pia gret
remorse for leaving the bar without
relieving oneself molly squatted behind
a bush to deal with her pee gret ninja
sex silent intercourse while your
roommate sleeps Jenni and Jeff had ninja
sex while Molly was passed out college
morning the afternoon see you first
thing in the college morning so like 1
p.m. for more definitions visit
urbandictionary.com while you're there
be sure to look up a disaster bait it's
funny and sad
you